I mean Madison warned us against
devolving into a two-party system and we
see why now
hi I'm Zack Weiss molar for recent TV
here with Mark Madsen sitting three
terms state senator from Utah
he recently switched his party
affiliation from Republican to
libertarian and we're here to find out
why mark thank you very much for talking
to us great to be here welcome to Utah
so why did you do it why'd you switch
from Republican to libertarian well it
had been in the in my mind for some time
I had been considering it seriously for
actually a couple of years before I did
it
and I didn't move on it because I had
other important issues some bills I
wanted to try and work and I didn't want
that to be a distraction I didn't want
to lose my committee chair position I
wanted to be able to do everything I
could for the for the issues I believed
in and I realized that I would
compromise that because of our two-party
system if I did it earlier being elected
as a delegate to go to the National
Convention going to Cleveland having the
Cleveland experience from the Utah's
perspective which was not necessarily a
pleasant experience and the moment just
seemed right I mean it was almost as if
there was a reason for my waiting tell
us a little bit about the Cleveland
experience the Republican National
Convention
from your perspective what happened
there and why did it sour you ultimately
on the looking there were a few things
that had happened over the over the
series of days but the probably the the
the most striking was the fact that I
couldn't cast my vote for the candidate
that I had been sent there to vote for
at least in the first round even if I'd
have been allowed to cast my vote crews
still would not have been the nominee
but to go there at your own expense to
be nominated and then have your vote
counted for Trump in the first round was
bothersome the tension and the energy
and the negativity at that moment as he
was being shouted down the epithets that
were that were thrown at the Utah
delegation it was hostile I mean it was
finger-pointing spittle from the mouth
very passionate and it was hatred
against the Utah for what they were
trying to do is for under what I think
stand by our principles my observation
is that there
- wings within the Republican Party I
call it the Jeffersonian wing and the
Roosevelt wing you've got two different
philosophies you know Roosevelt a
renowned progressive the in turn of the
century a very activist government trust
busters and Jefferson who is the the
Mentalist in the you know the the tree
of liberty is watered with the blood of
tyrants type
I think the worm has turned I believe
that that the Jeffersonian wing is now a
distinct distinct minority
I always referred to myself in the
legislature as a very small minority
within the majority party do you find
much support among your constituents for
Jeffersonian ideals or libertarian
ideals I know those are in some ways
separate things but related I represent
and the people I interact with have been
very supportive under understanding and
they've at least given me an opportunity
to try and explain my reasons why and
and after having had that opportunity
most of them even if they don't agree
they understand my issue is I thought
the Republican Party set stood for a
certain set of ideals and my frustration
was people who would paint themselves
red carry the Republican banner and and
take advantage of those set of ideals to
get elected and and used them
rhetorically and then never even think
about applying them to policy once they
got elected or there are other areas
besides you know gun rights the where
you feel like the Republican Party here
is falling short in terms of protecting
constitutional rights and civil
liberties I have an a rating with the
NRA now I also have an A rating with the
ACLU because I believe in all ten of the
Bill of Rights the surveillance state
the police state we have a lot of
shootings here some out the the racial
element here because this is so
homogeneous but we have a lot of cops
shooting citizens racist I mean we've
got issues on just protecting the basic
rights the Fourth Amendment we were
given a d-minus ranking by the Institute
for justice for our civil asset
forfeiture I mean it is horrendous I
don't believe that this is a state where
somebody who believes the principles I
believe in and wants to live by them can
own their life
own their choices own the consequences
without government getting in the middle
of it this is your last term which ends
in January so what exactly is the point
of leaving when you're not going to
continue in office do you have other
political ambitions it is essentially a
statement it's largely symbolic
I mean Madison warned us against
devolving into a two-party system and we
see why now the the you know the
polarization the inability to work
across party lines they door to come to
any kind of a common ground
I believe it's healthy to have more than
two to two parties I have worked in
other countries where they have some
places they have dozens of parties and I
said I see that that's a more healthy
system from my perspective so I wanted
to start that I wanted to expend
whatever political capital I had on
trying to give the Libertarian Party
maybe a little bump a little boost have
you experienced any criticism or
pushback from your colleagues or any
form of censure in our caucus I'm sure
there's folks that we're glad to see me
go anyway
because they don't like hearing the
things I believe in I think it's
appropriate that I be removed from my
chair positions I haven't argued against
I facilitated it those are the rules
and the rules should apply both ways no
no committee but also seat at the
legislative management and that's and
we're working through that we're sorting
through I wouldn't call it a censure but
it's a natural outcome of joining
another part it's a serious thing I've
been Republican forever do you think
there's any hope for libertarians in
Utah we're in a state that has highly
restrictive alcohol regulations let
alone marijuana that was yes another
very frustrating example of Utah being
out of step with other states that are
moving in a free the direction of
freedom conservative principles as far
as I see them and understand them and
that is lost on the majority of the
Republican representation in this state
the hypocrisy of people who call
themselves conservative and say how dare
Michelle Obama say I can't have salt on
my Big Mac okay fine
it is your life on your consequence but
they toggle off those
suppose when it's convenient or when
they think they know better and they say
oh we can't let people choose before it
between cannabis and opioids because why
do you think that there is a place going
forward for small-l libertarians such as
yourself or Rand Paul or maybe Mike
leaves some extent Justin Amash are
there gonna be more of those going
forward or as Trump totally demolished
that and as the libertarian army of the
future I speculate that Trump will weak
in the Republican Party post-election I
don't have a lot of confidence again in
either one of those two and their
ability to govern I think we're not in
great shape now as a country and I think
four years from now that may be the
critical moment we think things are bad
now four years from now maybe the time
the moment in history when when the
libertarians have to step up and save
the nation
ideally I'd love to have a couple of
people that that switch parties and form
a libertarian caucus and and follow
through and elect their own leadership
and have seats on the Appropriations
Committee and and establish themselves
as a legitimate minority party and
engage in policymaking here the
Democrats wield a lot of control when
you've got a bifurcated Republican Party
as I've described where you have the
Jeffersonian Roosevelt that you know
those Democrats can wield a lot of power
the minority party
can it can be the kingmaker the
Libertarian Party could have much the
same dynamic it could be a much sought
after a you know support group for
certain bills and again being inside
those rooms where those decisions are
made having an equal standing with the
other two parties would be huge